Chris Pratt is back on our screens after
his split from on a ferris Beyonce
throws jay-z a birthday shindig plus
your man is attempting the lemon dan hi
friends welcome back to the Daily dead
II it's been a minute since we've seen
Chris Pratt out and about just three
days ago he filed for divorce from Anna
Faris which still crushes my soul but I
digress
still Chris was sure in a good mood
outside Jimmy Kimmel yesterday signing
autographs for fans after 8 long day
now Pratt filled in for Kimmel last
night whose young son Billy just had his
second heart surgery
we're told Chris arrived around 9 a.m.
and rehearsed all day and despite being
censored five times you could say Chris
had the time of his life with musical
guest Chris Stapleton
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
meanwhile Chris Pratt and his Jurassic
world falling Kingdom co-star Bryce
Dallas Howard also stopped by Allen
today and apparently their five-year-old
kids a BFS and I asked him the other day
if you could have pizza with any one of
your friends who would it be
he was like Beatrice I had to text her
and tell her yeah it's so sweet really
have an incredible friendship it's it's
awesome and like getting I mean for me
with my childhood getting to be raised
kind of on sad young and with all the
kids who were kids of people working on
the movies it's sort of it's fulfilling
sort of like the dream of my own
childhood in a way knowing that that
they're getting to experience this and
they'll be friends for their whole life
now those two are already pounding
pavement to promote the Jurassic world
sequel which is not out until next
summer but the teaser trailer drops on
Thursday all right we'll listen there
were no kids in sight for Beyonce and
jay-z who were out celebrating Jays 48th
birthday
Beyonce threw her hubby a party and
instead of avoiding the paparazzi they
actually posed in an elevator that
opened up onto the street now they say a
picture is worth a thousand words and if
you look closely
Beyonce have the word unity stitched on
her sleeve could the two be poking fun
at that infamous elevator brawl you know
Jay versus Solange back in 2014 or maybe
the fact that they have come out on the
other side of infidelity and are crazy
and love again either way I think be
saying it's all good folks meanwhile I
had the pleasure of chatting with the
man behind Beyonce's iconic single
ladies dance B's lead choreographer Jack
well night and after seeing the slay he
brought to any Rd and Rihanna's lemon
video it all makes sense why Forbes just
named him one of their thirty young
artists and visionaries under 30 and of
course I also had to learn the latest
dance craze from the master himself okay
so now we got to talk about the present
time you're working with any of any Rd
on you choreographed the lemon video
which was so so dope I mean what's it
like working from those guys
oh my god you know Pharrell is just the
craziest artist you know like talk about
someone who's ahead of his time you know
and
someone who gets it you know so it's
been awesome time in the studio with him
you know heating such great energy and
his love is so real for the heart you
know and he's so proud of women you know
he's so he's like what he's like what
would lemon beat without the
choreography
you know like so it's such a great
project to be a part of you know what
inspired the choreography feel of it
it's meant a lot of time studying like
Soul Train performances from the
seventies and you know like Tina Turner
performances like what was that energy
back man that those that they had that
was so captivating you know and
mesmerized we can't look away you know
so I wanted that I wanted lemons to feel
like that you know and would celebrate
dad well you uh it's lightning in a
bottle man you have a knack for uh for
creating these dents whatever wants to
do and in fact this person wants to
learn are you ready to teach me lemon
are you ready to get know I'm ready I've
been watching the video all morning I go
yeah so I brought my good friend here
jasmine you know she's one of my
assistant choreographers on the project
you know and she has the Bob she the
answer's up the Bob you know okay
there's different dances and each one
has that all identity so what are we
learning today we're going to the lemon
the lemon the actual lemony naturally
show you Obama the Obama here that the
Obama okay okay is it Barack or Michelle
both okay we ready all right we're going
to close to the right you're gonna with
your head to the right Hey
and I am I doing it
[Music]
so the barman oh when I hit you're gonna
do a cross and well and then you kind of
kind of levitate on your leg I mean on
your feet you want to kind of levitating
you're like oh you got it light as a
feather
presidential okay should we try one
music music here we go bah and right
and now y'all got a party trick for your
next holiday get-together all right you
guys be sure to subscribe to our channel
and check back here tomorrow because
jaquail also gave me the scoop on what
he and Beyonce are cooking up for
Coachella you guys don't want to miss it
I'll see that I get a he'll live